can't be that hard right it's just a
little bit of hair ah oh no oh no a lot
of my co-workers have been pressuring me
into doing stuff with my eyebrows I've
gotten them waxed like once probably
when I was like 13 I get from my
Hispanic heritage the unibrow this is
like the cumulation of like me going
into surgery and not being a doctor and
having to you know take out someone's
heart I have no idea what I'm doing
these hairs on the edge they start to
get very faint but they keep going
there's like an especially dart like
that one right there boom my skin
supposed to stretch this far I literally
am like oh my goodness ah ah where
should I put the hair there's like meat
on the end of the hair boom that's a
hair like on the top of the head so do I
keep it here and then cut or do I sit
okay guys I was yeah these really tiny
tools I feel like like small children
are supposed to like operate these to
stab myself this is literally like
diffusing a bomb like if you go too far
usually you know you're dead it's like a
half throw cake I don't know how I
decided how much to cut with this it
looks like a Crayola crayon but it's for
your face I fear I might have chosen the
wrong color because it's really showing
up a lot lighter
it's like skin tone or hair time try to
match it oh that's a lot oh [ __ ] that's
as a glistening looking eyebrow that is
intense black was not a way to come I
feel like I took Ron Swanson's mustache
and stuck him like above my eyeballs I
think they look good
I will probably not prove my eyebrows
again unless I get you no more torture
from my coworkers I will never do this
again
you can put trimming it out grooming it
down you know thinning it out or you can
just color in all the bad parts with the
pencil hole like yeah is that an
official like way to like make your
eyebrows look prettier